TV host Andy Cohen is a coronavirus
survivor now he's in a new fight over a
policy preventing him from helping other
patients just because he's gay FDA
guidelines prevent men from donating
blood plasma if they've had sex with
another man in the past three months
but plasma from survivors may contain
antibodies which could help fight the
virus Cohen as you know as a host have
watched if watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen that's how you say it and he
joins us from his home in New York City
good morning to you Andy Cohen really
good to see you hi my friend how are you
hi I'm really glad to see you back up
and running there was a lot of chatter
over the weekend about this many people
outraged that you were treated this way
yet still others say well wait a second
there could be a health risk here what
was your response to the government's
thanks but no thanks to you well you
know I was disappointed I've known in
the past about about the fact that gay
men cannot donate blood but I think
we're in an unusual situation right now
this is we're in a war against a disease
that we don't know a lot about and
there's an urgent need for the antibody
that is in people like me who've
survived by who've survived coronavirus
so I just felt like you know blood
donations are down over a hundred and
fifty thousand there are a hundred and
fifty thousand less people donating
blood right now so there's an urgent
need and a special urgent need for the
blood that I have so I was disappointed
I want to help I think that the rules
should be looked at again by the FDA
there are there have been great strides
in testing for HIV since these rules
were enacted you can get an HIV test in
20 minutes they I know screen the blood
again a second time after you donate it
to make sure there's not HIV in the
blood so I just think this needs another
examination
we're in an unusual moment in time right
now there is a war going on and we're
all being asked to adapt and I think the
FDA should do no and that's an important
point you make that the blood is tested
and you get the results back within 20
minutes listen this original ban was
enacted in my understanding in 1983 to
prevent potential HIV transmission and
now we're sitting here in 2020 and so it
sounds like you're saying we need to
re-evaluate these it seems archaic at
this point or a lot of people it does
you know we're all being asked to adapt
in so many ways to new things in life
and we're doing it for the greater good
as a community and I think this is
something that the FDA should take a
look at and say how can we move forward
this is an FDA thing by the way it's not
a red cross thing it's not the hospital
that I applied to give my blood to it
all comes to the FDA
well the FDA's told us in a statement
quote they're working on a pilot study
with 2,000 men to determine whether an
individual risk assessment questionnaire
would be as effective as a current
policy does that make sense to you
listen if they're working on something
that makes me happy I don't know how
long that's gonna take
I just want to give my blood you know
what I mean I want to help and so that's
that's what I'm looking to do and that's
why I'm talking about this by the way
you want blood donations are down by the
way if you're someone who's watching and
you survived coronavirus go give blood
it is needed and appreciate it and
that's why you're speaking of Andy but I
just want to say you look good do you
feel as good as you look because I'm
wondering what the experience was like
for you you scared a lot of people and
there's so many different experiences
about this there are I had a great
friend who had coronavirus and he was
about four days ahead of me in terms of
the virus working its way through his
system so I was talking to him
every day and finding out where he was I
had a less severe case than he did but I
feel good I feel strong and now I'm just
trying to help and pitch in and do what
I can
just as a citizen well I know I would
think part of the hardest part would be
being separated from your favorite son
Benjamin who by the way was voted cutest
baby of all time in People magazine did
you see that so how did you navigate
that because you t-shirt cutest baby
alive Gale cutest baby alive I heard how
did you navigate with him in the same
house how did you work that out it stunk
man he was down the hall I was in my
room basically shut out from
civilization for 13 days and you know it
was a killer I could hear him I was
watching him on the nanny cam thank God
I have an incredible caretaker for him
who really did yeoman's work but it was
not it was not great man
gale is that the room that I would stay
in if I crashed at your house no you
would stay in the guest room I actually
have a guest room with a separate
bathroom you would be well taken care of
Andy where we go how are you finding
happiness during these times Andy Cohen
how is it working how are you doing that
I am finding happiness actually by by by
leaning into hosting watch what happens
live from home every night we're having
a great time and it's making me happy
that my staff is employed and engaged
and we're getting to take people's minds
off of the serious issues of the day and
like lean into some fun and cocktails at
the end of the night every night on
Bravo Andy Cohen don't ever change we're
glad you're back we're glad you're
healthy always good to see you thank you
very much we'll be right back